he's really going to begin now you'll
get these questions a lot and they
appear a lot into unit by the way so we
really want to master this skill you
should be suspicious of this right you
remember I said I'll often give you
questions that will shed light on other
questions right so that you can see the
connections between them which question
on the board is closest to this one
it's just the very first one right this
guy is more or less identical this right
it's just that I popped in a pretty room
I've said what's X except you already
know what X is right so it's reasonable
to say x equals 30 degrees it certainly
works for us before didn't know ok now
that's our intuition you can go to your
calculator right and you can confirm
this as well by saying see how at let's
say this point here you remember will
say do something to both sides do
something to both sides so that you can
simplify these right well what would I
do to both sides here to get that X by
itself so it's simpler right and the
extras if I want to get rid of sine
you've used this before even as early as
last year on your calculator above the
sine button where is it there is you've
got this little thing which says I'll
even draw it for you right above it
you've got this guy okay there's a sign
this little minus one in the index okay
what's that big hold become sine inverse
very good please despite the fact of how
it looks please don't read that as sine
to the minus one that minus one is meant
to indicate I want you to undo whatever
side did I want you to undo it we have a
technical name for this is called an
inverse function which is why we have
this right it's like like do we get in
Reverse okay so being that I want to use
sine inverse here right to confirm this
result I can try this I can write this
down and then I can pop it in my
calculator I'm going to do sine inverse
to both sides that'll get rid of sine
here and it'll put sine inverse over
here on the right hand side okay
this is just like if you have equation x
over two you multiply both sides by two
no big deal
same thing to both sides now go ahead
test it up go to calculator press shift
sign [ __ ] sorry and Chuck point five in
there and sure enough right it tells you
yeah you were right the first time
x equals fade no big deal the only
problem is it's wrong kind of okay so
let me explain right Fabry's is one of
the answers oh yeah I mean you told me
that right at the start the lesson okay
but it's not the only itself do you see
any questions here right remember how I
was like I'll test out minus five and
it'll work okay I put it in it checks
out okay but I can also put in two
quadratics right quadratic equations
they have multiple solutions that
usually have two right trigonometric
equations just like quadratic equations
they also have multiple solutions and to
prove it to you I'm going to ask you to
go back to where you were doing this yes
sir all those graphs there can you turn
back I'm in four pages however many it
is for you and go to those graphs
okay once you turn there I actually want
you to take this sine graph and it is
worth if your sine graph doesn't look
like nice and clean like if there's
extra stuff on it like say this one see
I've got lots of extra stuff in there
because we were trying to graph it in
this way I want you to take your graph
and make me a little copy on your fresh
page based on what you've drawn before
make me a new sign I do if any one these
rollers
once you join I'd like you to look up
just sign that you're ready cuz this
next part is going to be quite a visual
so I'm going to ask you to watch it best
before you draw it as well
okay that's why if you're not finished
it's roughly enough time put your pens
down for a second and watch what happens
next because this is a crucial idea
remember I asked you to solve this pair
of equations over here write x squared
plus 3x minus 4 is 0 and then the same
thing why did I do that because I wanted
to illustrate something this is my graph
of y equals that that same quadratic
that you were solving and working with
before ok
x squared plus 3x minus 4 now how do I
know it looks like this there's a few
things I can say number one can you see
this is our it's a smiley it's a facing
up parabola it's not a facing down
parabola how do I know there's a single
number that tells me it's going up about
going down Kenny won't tell me which
number it is it's it's because as a plus
the plus I'm interested in is what it's
actually hiding it's the 1 in front of
the x squared right now when you write a
number like 7 we don't you say oh it's
plus 7 you kind of assume it's positive
right so nothing is written there but
there really is a plus sign there if I
wanted this thing to be facing down
there'd be a minus sign there and then
there isn't okay so it's going on right
now I also know that I've got this point
here and this point here which are 1 and
negative 4 how do I know that how do I
know that those are the values where it
hits the x axis how I know those are the
intercepts
I know because you told me right there
it is right there
you factorized it you factorize it and
you told me x squared plus 3x minus for
this graph it's equal to zero at these
points with zero here zero right there's
the x-axis right so at x equals negative
4 and x equals 1 the graph is equal to
zero okay another way I could say this
is like the coordinates of these points
are minus 4 comma 0 right
there is it equal 0 and 1 comma 0 okay
you happy with that
okay now how do I look at this next
equation it's very sneaky right why did
I write it like this why not just give
it to you in this form because that's
the one you can factorize and then solve
okay I wanted to show you there's a
relationship between these if solving
this gives me these two values right
then solving this will give me a
different pair values it'll give me
let's say question
these two values up here see if I can
get this across to you right when we say
would you please solve this equation for
me would you solve this one you're
thinking about as what values of x
cannot put in and it will work and
that's fine that is true okay but it's
more than that right when I say solve
what you see on the left hand side is a
graph there is right what you see on the
right hand side is also a graph it's the
x-axis y equals 0 right and what I'm
looking for when you solve is tell me
where they collide tell me where they
intersect tell me where they're equal to
each other right so these happen to be
the two places where that graph and that
graph are equal right so when you go
ahead and solve this question I'm asking
where is this graph equal to that graph
right there is up the top there
there's my y equals 6 graph okay so
where do they intersect and you told me
at negative 5 & 2 right by the way do
you see it has to be that way because
this shape is symmetric or negative 4 to
negative 5 is 1 unit that way 1 to 2 is
1 unit this way okay so I'm sort of
going just out of it further and here
are my Y coordinates okay